we should do a check on the weather Brad
how's it looking out there looks uh
pretty good
yeah thanks Brad Brad Pitt ladies and
gentlemen oscar-winner slash weatherman
the 56 year old actor made a surprise
cameo on Sunday's episode of John
Krasinski's some good news
internet show which has been pretty
freaking cute highlighting positive news
amid the ongoing coronavirus pandemic
if you are at risk and you need help
getting essential items let me know and
I will do what I can to help
it says mailman Kyle and my phone number
and I delivered a little under 400 of
those notes and I have heard something
from pretty much every person and while
most of the show was a recap on John's
Virtual prom brad popped in halfway
through to give an update on the weather
we should do a check on the weather Brad
how's it looking out there
looks uh pretty good
yeah thanks Brad okay so maybe Brad
shouldn't quit his day job looks uh
pretty good
yeah just sayin yeah but this actually
isn't the first time that Brad has given
it a go to help us understand climate
change and what it means the world he is
our own Jim Jefferies Oh weatherman
how's it looking out there weatherman
thank you Jim
so things are going to be getting warmer
in this area here and this area here
thank you Jim Jefferies our weatherman
do you have any future forecasts for us
there is no future yeah brad has made
several appearances on the Jim Jefferies
show serving up some super depressing
weather forecasts how's it looking out
there weatherman well Jim carbon dioxide
is slowly turning our planet into an
uninhabitable wasteland and half the
population don't believe it depressing
yes but damn he makes the weather look
good so what's the forecast the forecast
is we're all going to die and there'll
be no one left to remember our stories
thank you as always where the man sure
thank you
[Music]